et la parole est à monsieur philippe
gosselin merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et j'y associe
aussi mon collègue guénhaël huet les
agriculteurs souffrent ils sont en
détresse vous le savez particulièrement
les jeunes qui ont choisi l'élevage en
cause la guerre des prix du lait de la
viande en particulier du port nos
éleveurs porcins vont aussi très mal
vous le savez sans oublier la filière
légumière face aux transformateurs aux
salaisonniers à la grande distribution
les agriculteurs ne peuvent lutter les
prix sont trop bas ils produisent à
perte
dans mon département la manche la
production de 1000 litres de lait
revient à 379 euros
or le prix moyen payé et de 356 fait la
différence et elle est de 23 euros
la loi amont voté par cette majorité
prédit le coût des matières premières
est supérieur de 25% du prix de vente
alors le prix d'achat doit être revue à
la hausse
ce mécanisme régulateur entre
producteurs industriels distributeurs et
là ce n'est pas appliquée et nous
souhaiterions les agriculteurs
souhaiterait que l'état enclenche enfin
la mécanique en cause également bien sûr
l'accès au foncier qui est de plus en
plus coûteux décourager les jeunes sont
de moins en moins nombreux à s'installer
vous le savez aussi et à terme c'est le
renouvellement des générations qui s'en
trouvera menacée il faut également
mentionner dans plusieurs départements
le retard dans le paiement des dotation
jeune agriculteur avec un impact bien
sûr négatif sur les trésoreries
il ya quelques semaines j'avais demandé
la création d'une mission d'information
sur la concurrence dans
l'agroalimentaire il est en effet urgent
monsieur le ministre les membres du
gouvernement d'examiner de près la
réalité économique et le rapport de
force qui est déséquilibrée entre
l'amont et l'aval
ce sont toutes les filières qui sont
concernés
monsieur le ministre ce vendredi les
producteurs de porcs se réuniront à
ploërmel la semaine prochaine ce seront
les jeunes agriculteurs qui se réuniront
chez vous dans la sarthe et les uns
comme les autres attendent des actes
l'état est-il à leur côté peuvent ils
compter sur l'état peuvent ils compter
sur vous eh oui si oui comment
je vous remercie
car monsieur stéphane le foll ministre
de l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire et
de la forêt ce président est monsieur le
député vous avez évoqué l'ensemble des
filières agricoles qui aujourd'hui
connaissent de graves difficultés elles
sont effectivement lié à l'élevage sur
cette question vous avez évoqué aussi
d'ailleurs la loi consommation qui est
venu je vous le dis quand même corriger
ce qu'avait été la loi de modernisation
de l'économie qui avait mis beaucoup
trop de concurrence est beaucoup trop de
poids à la grande distribution donc nous
sommes en train de corriger un effet
durable malheureusement de ce qui a été
un déséquilibre dans les filières entre
les différents maillons de ces filières
que ce soit surtout sur la production la
transformation et la grande distribution
hier on a lu et j'ai eu à plusieurs
occasions
la volonté de rassembler l'ensemble de
ses maillons de la filière pour
expliquer à chacun qu'aujourd'hui en
particulier quand on est dans une phase
de faible inflation
la pression qui s'exerce sur la
production est trop fort elle conduit
aujourd'hui dans la filière porcine en
particulier à avoir les difficultés que
vous avez évoqué j'aurai l'occasion dès
vendredi
et j'irai à pouvoir mail qu'il ya des
choses qui sont en train de se faire on
a engagé les discussions pour voir
comment on pouvait faire pour réévaluer
le prix ce qui n'est pas si simple
et j'aurai l'occasion de prendre un
arrêté et décret qui sera le premier qui
aurait été pris par un ministre de
l'agriculture pour encadrer des
promotions commerciales
c'est ce que je dirai vendredi vous avez
aussi évoqué l'application de la loi
consommation
on en a discuté avec le ministre de
l'économie emmanuel macron dès que les
indices parce qu'on est obligé de
s'appuyer sur des indices seront
cohérent et convergents nous
appliquerons strictement la loi
consommation et nous demanderons des
renégociations de prix sur les prix qui
ont été négociées il ya à peine
d'ailleurs à moi parce que on doit tenir
compte des coûts de production pour
intégrer ses coûts de production dans le
prix de vente donc sur ces questions le
ministre de l'agriculture
l'état est aux côtés des agriculteurs il
a été il le sera aujourd'hui et demain
merci monsieur ministre n'a pas